Justin Bieber's war of words with Selena
Gomez Justin's new romance with Sophia
Ritchie sparked his supposed feud with
Selena fans are upset they're dating and
justin is upset with his fans for not
accepting his new lady he threatened to
make his Instagram private saying quote
if you guys are really fans you wouldn't
be so mean to people that I like selena
is supposedly commented on that photo
quote if you can't handle the hate then
stop posting pictures of your girlfriend
LOL don't be mad at your fans what do
you mean Justin allegedly responded it's
funny to see people that use me for
attention and still try to point the
finger at this way sad I'll love but the
battle between the exes didn't stop
there both seemingly accused the other
of cheating Selena claimed Justin
cheated multiple times Justin retaliated
again quote I cheated oh I forgot about
you and dane as in Zayn Malik in March
Selena squashed the romance rumours
between her and the former one direction
singer and she appeared to take one last
dig at Justin posting a disc collage of
photos with fans just hanging out with
these kids it makes you re-evaluate your
life sometimes
you